hey everybody its Jesse and I hope
everyone had a good weekend
today I'm streaming a little bit earlier
than normal to an hour earlier because
the Eclipse is today and so around like
2:30 I think there's going to be a
partial eclipse where I am so I guess
like if I would have drove maybe five or
six hours south west of where I am I
could have seen a full Eclipse I thought
about it but I didn't decided not to do
it so today I think we're just gonna
work on styling so this is this is where
the projects at right now basically all
of the content that was that's on the
current app is here it's it's in our new
react version so we have that all in
there we have the the forms we have two
forms one of the form is is working we
just I don't have all the information to
finish that form yet we have another
form that we just we hadn't hooked up
yet in our our server to be able to send
the data where we needed to go that's
not really going to be a big deal since
we've already done it with one form we
just do it again for the other one yes
there's just not there's not really any
major things left to do it's just kind
of fine-tuning and testing and then
getting feedback from the rest of my
department and new content from the rest
of my department because I think
I've talked to a few people about it and
I think that we're gonna add some
sections and change the language in some
of the sections so I obviously can't do
that and so I know for sure what content
is needed so I'm gonna do my best to get
that going and make sure to remind
everyone to think about what they want
on here and get something to me you know
sooner rather than later so I was
thinking I'd start out maybe on the
homepage and making things look a little
bit nicer so this is gonna be a good
stream for newer people maybe people who
are just starting out because it's going
to be more like CSS not not really a lot
of you know we're not really gonna work
on the server not really a lot of things
that are getting like really into react
and it'll be a somewhat short stream I
want to get things done I guess within
an hour so let me see
actually let me know let me know if
everything's all right with the stream
we have a lot fewer of yours than normal
so that's kind of odd I wonder the last
time this happened something something
happened with the YouTube notifications
and a lot of people didn't get them so I
know there's a delay so I'll wait I'll
wait uh maybe 30 seconds to see if
anybody responds I want to make sure I'm
not didn't do something wrong setting up
the video
okay cool y-yes I got a response
everything seems alright okay it's
possible that maybe it wasn't something
wrong with the YouTube notifications
again but I'm just I'm gonna get started
and if people join great if not that's
not a problem either I got to do my work
either way so let me let me see I'm kind
of thinking it might be nice to add in
so we have a new logo that's not being
used in very many places right now it
would probably be nice to put it here so
that everybody would see what with the
new web logo is you know eventually
that's going to be used on all the sites
also I'd like to try changing this a bit
because we're going with a different
look in some of our projects so I'm
gonna work on this for now probably need
we talked about before doing something
here
to make these look a bit nicer as well
oh I do want to thank thank Matt for his
pull request so a lot of good stuff in
the pull request you can check it out it
was poor request 80 or 48 there's just
so much stuff I could spend like half
hour going over all the stuff so I'm not
going to but basically fix them some
like little errors that were happening
and also made a lot of components into
stateless functional components any
components that could be made into them
so really really cool and I really
appreciate it I mean it was it was a lot
of work all of our content
I could probably the biggest thing that
you'll notice if you're working on this
on this repo is that
almost all of the content now is in data
in these data files and is pulled in so
the components themselves look a lot
cleaner a breakpoint said Eclipse cast
the question mark yeah I thought about
trying to do something I had on maybe I
could do one on my my Instagram stream
stream with the Eclipse Eclipse it looks
like that might be cool I don't have any
of those special glasses though that
they say you need or else you'll damage
your eyes so hopefully I'll figure
something out and I won't go blind
all right so I'm gonna bring over dev
tools we're going to be working mostly
in dev tools and then once we get it you
know looking about how we want it then
I'll I'll switch over and put that in an
actual sass file so let's take a look at
all right structure here so right now we
have the background color is green I
want to change that and let's make it
white and I wanted to set a order bottom
and I'm gonna do let's see I'm gonna try
three pixels solid and I want it to be a
gold I'm gonna have to I thought I had
the style guide open somewhere so I
could grab that color I used to have
some of the hex colors memorized for the
university color palette because I use
them so much but then when I started
using sass variables instead I didn't
have to know the hex colors and I forgot
them all I do remember the green still
but I forgot all the rest of them
alright so on my other screen I'm just
gonna find this hex code and copy it
over
oops
up those the wrong one I got the yellow
you need the gold
area
okay
yeah that looks about like what we were
going with we need to make this green
why don't I even have the color here
that's
that was odd I wonder if I did I put
that color in or was that there in the
framework because anyway normally in an
SVG you don't have to worry about color
it's fill that you want so I don't I
don't really remember if if I put that
on there before it's possible but I did
accidentally okay now we have the words
Resource Center which I guess that will
get left that yeah that'll get left and
I think I'll leave the words Resource
Center in and let's also make that this
green
alright now we want to grab the the logo
which let me find the logo also let me
start my Pomodoro timer it's I don't
think I've actually used this logo
anywhere yet so I have to take a second
to find it maybe I think I actually I
had an SVG version of it that I was
working on and sketch yes it is so you
can check it out here's the logo
this is actually my edited version of
the logo so it had a much bigger border
radius that I didn't like
so I Shrunk the border radius under two
pixels and yet so we'll see so I I was
trying to get officially get the border
radius changed and it never really I
didn't really push it and we didn't come
to a decision about it so I think I'm
gonna use this one and just see what see
what everyone thinks if anyone even
notices and yeah I mean I may have to
change it or this may be the beginning
of getting it changed it's still at a
point now where we haven't used this
logo enough that you know we need to
keep it consistent it's definitely early
on so we could change things at least I
think we could change things before it's
official but anyway yeah this is the new
the new web version of the logo the main
benefit to this as opposed to the other
one is all our other logos actually
spelled out the words Franciscan
University of Steubenville and to do
that you have to
small font so the logo had to be quite
large to make the font readable so then
you were you were limited and with where
you could put the logo it had to be in a
spot that was big enough so like we
could never use the real logo in a
header that was this short because you
wouldn't be able to read the text so
it's definitely some benefits to this
and really for this university probably
the iconic thing is this here
people know this so as long as that's
there you know it doesn't necessarily
matter as much about whatever's after
that you know people who know the
university will recognize that let's see
so I'm gonna grab I don't know where I
saved this that I'll just export it
again if you're not familiar with this
program and I'm using it's called sketch
it's it's like a design program so I
don't I'm not really great with
Photoshop so this is what I use for the
small amount of design work like this
that I do occasionally if I have a
client and I need to do some mock-ups I
will use cap sketch for that it's Mac
only and it's not bad I think it was
about a hundred dollars and that's
that's not a like recurring cost just
hundred always flat fee and then you
have sketch you have all the updates and
everything so I like it although I
haven't really tried a lot of other
programs so maybe there's something
better out there but this is as worked
for me for what I need to use it and
obviously there we go export so I don't
use this often enough to be really good
with it
SVG yep great
it looks like I already have it exported
where is this folder
I will just search for it then
all right whoa
all right so this is the the code I
guess for the the mark-up for the SVG
you see I've done nothing to to shrink
this down so I'm sure there's stuff that
could be done for now I just want to see
how it looks so we're gonna use this
let's so we'll just bring this in do we
have I don't know that we have a place
where we're putting images do we know we
don't okay so let me make a folder for
images
actually I'm just gonna make a new file
okay set in there we go
see
I can't remember where I have what
component I have the code for the Navin
is it inside now
all right it's it it's inside Navi is a
slightly misleading maybe I shouldn't
have named it that okay alright so I am
using the component for material UI so
I'm assuming that there's a way to put a
logo in
maybe
maybe this will work let's see
alright let's see what that does not not
hopeful that that will work oh no we
lost all our styles I never I forgot to
take him out of dev tools oh well we
didn't really do that much so won't
really be a problem but whatever I just
did here didn't do anything so let's
let's put in some styles for this before
we before we do anything else
there we go and I'm gonna put the styles
for this and app because this is a
standard component it'll be on every
single page I guess I could make
something for side nav but I think this
is OK
alright so I just need to know what
these the names are here
it looks like it's not there's no class
names on it so maybe I'll have to author
you either give it a class name or I
think I'll give it a class name I'm sure
I could pass in some styles using you
know the way set out here in material UI
but I'd rather work in sass and apply
the Styles like that okay yeah so that's
pretty standard class name works most of
the time the only time class name hasn't
worked for me is if like I've kind of
extended a component like in that
generic component card I can't just put
a class name right on the generic
component element and have it work
okay we're just gonna give a class name
of app bar and then we should be able to
go with a poor background color white
water bottom solid
let me grab that color
and what else to be
let's just make sure that works first
okay we did get the border on the bottom
but maybe for some reason you know what
these are all uh I don't know I didn't
see this before these are all in line so
to override this I'm either gonna have
to use important or I'll have to change
change these let me go back here
okay I can override with the style yeah
I'll probably I guess that's better than
using important in my CSS
okay that works
and what I'm not sure about is so these
interior sections here also have inline
styles so I could try to do something
like this but I don't think it'll work
see it doesn't go down to this so I'm
not
so I may have to just use important on
there to get that to work
so since I'm using sass instead of
regular CSS I can nest
I can nest these which is basically same
as if I were to type out a bar and then
space h1 so if you're not familiar with
sass the syntax probably looks a little
weird but that's all that's going on
here
I'm just gonna double check just to make
sure I yeah like I thought it wouldn't
need add that important in there
all right so normally it's not a great
idea to use important because now at any
point that guy I can't really override
that even with inline Styles so like
once you do that you kind of break the
cascading nature of cascading style
sheets for that element at least but in
this case I could do this right now and
get it to work and I know I'm never
gonna want this to change for that
element so I'm okay with that or I could
try to read documentation on material UI
more and figure out some other way to do
it
so it's possible later on if I maybe
I'll figure it out and I can change this
but for now this is the easiest way to
do it and I know it will work but like I
said you don't want to just use this all
the time sometimes it's really easy and
quick to do it but it will make
maintaining things later on harder so
use it sparingly
I guess that's that's what I try to use
it sparingly I probably use it too much
as it is the alright so what it looks
like we messed up I'm assuming when I
did this that's why when I messed up the
icon there yeah so now we can see let's
target that SVG
and we want that the fill you want the
fill also to be oops
I know I'm typing up the hex codes here
I don't really need to I could save him
his variables but I just kind of wanted
to see how it was going oh did that now
that didn't work
oops forgot the important
there we go still alright so that's
about where we were before I
accidentally I got rid of all the stuff
we've done in dev tools so now the next
step let me check my Pomodoro timer okay
next step is get that logo in there and
for that maybe I'll check this again
actually let me
okay I never really checked to see what
was happening with this so I want to
check because it's possible that this I
guess put this element in there and the
path is just wrong
I'm not really sure what path I should
use for this I knew with next J asked
what the path was supposed to be but I'm
not really sure what it's supposed to be
with create react app so let's check
that out and it looks like Oh awesome so
we did get it is there I mean we don't I
want to find some other way to put it in
here because I need that button as well
but this is what we wanted I think we
just probably don't have the right path
hmm
okay let's see
let me see I'm gonna check in the live
chat see if anybody the users create
react app knows what so if anybody uses
create react app and just knows offhand
what the pass should be let me know
otherwise I'm just gonna play around
with it a little bit and see if I could
figure it out let me see
just
okay my timer just went off so I did
find something to try for the the image
but I'm going to take five minute break
to go to the live chat probably won't
need all five minutes because there's
not a lot going on in the live chat
today but hey everybody
that's that's watching and it's in the
chat
no cool Patrick Patrick has some
eclipses info in the live chat
oh cool so I mentioned earlier that I
don't have Eclipse glasses and Patrick
linked some directions to making a an
eclipse if you were so thank you I said
you just need two pieces of paper and a
thumbtack detect to make a pinhole cool
oh sorry so patrick said sketch went to
a yearly fee I did not know that so I'm
sorry for misinforming you all so I
guess whenever I got it
there was not a yearly fee so maybe
maybe I'm just allowed to have it still
since I got in earlier
oh cool patch you know what Patrick
that's right I you're in Tennessee right
so you're right in the path I was I was
thinking about going driving down to
Tennessee or flying down to Tennessee so
my wife has family there and I thought
that would be really cool I could go
down there I could just you know stay
with her family and see the Eclipse but
it seemed like I don't know it's it's
seemed like it would be no other thing
to do to take a day off work and just to
go down and Washington cliffs for a few
minutes come back
oh cool Gavin said I should take well or
probably Patrick will have the better
view
so Patrick should Gavin said take some
pics and vids and send them to slag so
if I'll try to I'll definitely try take
some video and pictures of it but
Patrick's gonna have the best the best
view out of anyone so I think where I'm
at they said it was going to be like 80%
obscured oh so the Sun will be 80%
obscured by the moon which I guess is
not bad but it's definitely not a fool
full of cliffs
okay so patrick said he doesn't have a
solar filter for the camera so so you
need a filter then if if I tried to take
a video of this with my phone am I going
to break my phone's camera or what
our cool Gavin said he's totally up to
date with the videos that's awesome
that's that's a really impressive who's
with quite a few videos it's really cool
oh wow so Brandon thanks for that info
so Brandon says not to take pictures and
videos because I I will break the phone
all rohan says the phone camera should
be okay without without filters says
it's the larger sensors that can be
damaged but patrick says that actually
we saw a video where the sensor on a
camera got melted yeah we'll see maybe
I'll rethink this
okay cool so my my time is up so I'm
gonna get back to work on this so I'm
gonna try something and this is I don't
think I've ever done anything this way
before but it looks pretty cool so let
me try this so I'm going to I mean it
makes a lot of sense now that I saw it
but I just had not thought of it at all
so I'm going to import logo from
shoot now how am i darkness
here we go
now I'm not sure if this will work say I
didn't scroll down and the there's an
issue and create reactive about this
so after scrolling down I'm not sure if
this will work but let's let's try it
and see if I can import since what are
there to be liked
whereas
we can get this to it no cure so uh
alright so I need to do this
I just look back to the live chat and
I'll just mention this since we were
talking about it a minute ago
but breakpoint said I took pics with my
phone of the Sun no issues
now Brandon Brandon says I'm a
photographer don't risk it actually the
guy that works in the office next to me
is a photographer a really good
photographer so I will ask him just to
be sure he actually has like proper
lenses or something for it so actually
if he takes good pictures I will have
him send me the pictures and then I will
post the pictures I won't try to mess up
my my phone I'd rather not I bought I
bought like the new pixel when it came
out and that's like the most I've ever
spent on a phone so I wanted to last
longer than a year at least that's it
hasn't been a year yet alright so back
to this why can't I I have to be missing
something just really simple there's
this just can't be this can't be that
difficult
alright somebody said they did it like
this and on stackoverflow it works
all right still not
alright let's try the documentation for
create react app which is what I should
have looked first
all right so from what I'm seeing on the
documentation it looks like this should
work right so
okay I can't do with sgv SVG for
house
so let's see what to do with SVG
actually I have an idea let's do it like
this I'm gonna make
it's
you're gonna grab just some of this
markup to make things easier and so my
idea is I'm just going to put this SVG
in here
yeah so I'm gonna grab the SVG I'm gonna
take this out of here
so I'm think I need that
probably gonna have to change something
somewhere I'll be surprised if all of
these attributes work and react but
we'll see what the error message says we
can get rid of this and then let's just
change this to
and let's see you know how we can bring
in and for it
oops isn't that what I wanted to do
click the wrong thing there we go side
now that's I wanted
just go go and then here we're gonna put
let's try that okay cool let's get rid
of just get rid of this
I took it out okay
oops Rapha
this is a function
hmm
it's just
all right so I'm gonna I'm not sure what
this error is telling me I'm maybe you
can't just put an SVG in like that let
me get rid of some stuff
see
mm yeah I still get the same error okay
I definitely did not think adding the
logo would be this difficult
I've added SVG's and but they view in
small SVG so not really complicated so
I'm not sure I mean I guess there's
something in here that react is not like
oh why am i checking that it's giving me
the same error here okay
I was checking the wrong page okay
hey Sebastian Sebastian is asking where
I'm adding the logo so I'm trying to add
the logo in maybe that's let's let's
just test this first without trying to
pass this to another component just take
this
let's just shut he uses somewhere else
oops no it's not the right path for this
one huh
okay so still having the same same issue
all right so that's that's not gonna
work out there I guess I could not use
the SVG version and just convert it I'd
really rather not do that
didn't
I wonder if I could wrap this in this
SVG icon if that would make a difference
all right so this will probably be my
last attempt since I had a a to finish
this this stream soon I guess
yeah same thing alright well I will try
to missing and wait the SVG name is
wrong all right so I just checked
I knew I just checked the live chat and
I think I'm missing a nose somewhere FUS
log all right let me where am I missing
this
if you say
oh that's where I'm missing it huh Wow
okay if this works now
all right let's let's take it out of
here
and let's go with what I was originally
gonna do that would be
it's not gonna import that here but I'm
gonna try
I see their worries oops that's not kind
of
ha
and okay wow I can't believe well you
know what it probably still wouldn't
worked even a photo caught the type
because this this I did not have either
this required so thanks Matt for giving
me the code to do this require in line
like that and thank you also Joseph for
catching that missing oh I don't know
how you saw that this must be so tiny on
your screen and actually I just now
realized that the font was a bit smaller
than I normally do for a stream so I
apologize for that
Wow okay we get the logo on there a lot
bigger than I want but we can sort that
out at a different time also we need to
keep the side nav icon in there as well
so got a little bit of a work to do for
this but Wow
I can't believe it took me that long and
it was pretty much just mostly due to a
typo
oh cool just zoomed awesome okay Joseph
said the import on the top will also
work so that's cool good to know so
maybe it it probably then would have
worked had I been able to spell anyway
thanks everybody I'm gonna wrap things
up and and get ready to watch this
Eclipse so hopefully I'll have my vision
and I won't ruin my my phone's camera so
I think I'll I don't I don't know how
I'm gonna look at it maybe I'm not I'm
just gonna look around and not at the
Eclipse but but hopefully my my
colleague will have some really good
photos from his camera
and I can share them with you all on the
select channel so I'll be back tomorrow
and hopefully tomorrow won't have such a
silly error as a typo but that happens
yeah so I'll probably do some work this
hopefully this will look a lot nicer by
the next stream and thank you for
watching
also let me know if something went wrong
with the YouTube notifications because
it was kind of the video was kind of
slow to pick up viewers so I know I did
start it early so that could be it but I
just want to know maybe I did something
wrong setting up the YouTube video so
just let me know but I'll see y'all
tomorrow
thank you so much for watching and for
helping me out and the live chat really
appreciate that and have a great day